we have done a video of the size
comparison of the movie monsters of 2021
a couple of months back but since then
the list has changed and there are quite
a few new entries that have appeared in
new movies and tv shows
and so here we are showcasing you the 15
biggest movie monsters till date with
december just around the corner and no
new monster movies on the calendar
anymore so this one will be the final of
the year
at number 15 we have carnage coming from
the movie venom let there be carnage
it's a new symbiote that is an offspring
of venom himself and attached itself to
the serial killer cletus cassidy carnage
is red with hints of black and can form
larger appendages and tentacles plus
bigger and deadlier weapons from his
constituted matter moreover he can grow
up to around 20 meters or 66 feet tall
in the final scenes of the movie
14 we have diablos from the movie
monster hunter diablos are launched by
peter vivens with powerful armor plating
covering much of their body their most
north-worldly feature is a pair of
massive solid bull-like horns above
their red eyes diablos also possess a
pair of tusk-like fangs and a large
spiny neck frill and their tail ends
with a heavy stubborn club that can be
used to ward off attackers they are
around 30 meters long or 100 feet
at number 13 we have starro this monster
is an entry from the dc extended
universe's movie suicide squad 2 star of
the conqueror or simply starro was a
gigantic starfish-like extraterrestrial
being imprisoned and is the primary
subject of project starfish star
actually lived a happy life floating in
outer space staring at the stars planets
and constellations and it was captured
by humans and when it was freed it grew
to a large size of around 100 feet tall
and took out its anger on the quarter
maltese population
at number 12 we have the great protector
next on the list we have a mystical
dragon called the great protector from
the movie shanghai and the 10 rings
while her real name is shen long which
means god dragon she is still not as big
as dragon balls shenron or shenlong she
is around 100 feet long or 30 meters and
is a serpentine white dragon with red
markings and powers such as magic and
water manipulation
number 11 the skull crawler now we have
the first entry from the monster verse
which is the skull crawler or otherwise
known as titanos cranium repton and it
appeared briefly in the monster movie
godzilla vs kong earlier this year it
was captured and contained in a facility
in hong kong and was only released to be
slaughtered by mecca godzilla this skull
crawler was bigger than the one seen in
skull island at roughly 200 feet tall
at number 10 we have the dweller in
darkness another entry from the movie
shangti and the ten rings the dweller in
darkness was a leader of the soul eaters
with the ability to absorb souls
thousands of years ago the dweller and
its army attempted to destroy a mystical
land called tallow until it was
imprisoned inside a mountain by the
great protected dragon the dweller in
darkness resembles a dragon if it was
merged with a symbiote and it is roughly
100 meters or 328 feet long
at number 9 godzilla's singular point
there were quite a few forms of this
version of the g-man and the series
godzilla singular point and they are the
aquatic form which is aquaticus then
next evolved form which is amphibia then
comes the insole like form called
terrestris and finally the ultimate form
ultima which is the biggest out of the
foe with a height of 100 meters or 328
feet in the final moments of the last
episode
at number eight we have gong these next
three entries are ones from the movie
godzilla vs kong and on the number eight
spot is the eighth wonder of the world
king kong
kong has grown to three times to height
as seen in the movie skull island of
2017. he now stands at 337 feet or 102
meters tall
at number seven we have godzilla next is
none other than a g-man himself from the
same movie godzilla vs gong here
godzilla retains the same height as in
king of the monsters which is 120 meters
or 393 feet tall which is roughly 40
feet taller than the original
monsterverse version of 2014 which was
around 355 feet
at number six we have mecca g
then we have the robot version of
godzilla and it is bigger than the big g
himself mechagodzilla has a rough
skeletal design which is way different
from the earlier touhou versions that
are kind of shiny and well polished this
mecca monster is 460 feet tall or 140
meters and absolutely dominated the
fight against godzilla before kong
intervened
number five manda
next comes a monster from godzilla
singular point called manda which was
quite a famous kaiju back in the day in
earlier incarnations of it in toho
movies manda here in the godzilla
singular point series is a long
serpentine monster that swims in groups
and are hunted by godzilla aquaticus
they retain their long serpentine body
but their head appears to be closely
resemble a goblin sharp crossed with a
pit viper instead of a traditional
dragon they are 210 meters long or
roughly 688 feet
on the fourth spot we have warbat and
this is the last entry from the
monstervilles and we have the hollow
earth giant snake diamond gold warbat or
earlier as nozuki these warbats travel
in pairs and are extremely long around
three times the height of gong they
resemble cobras and have the ability of
flying and gliding and they constrict
their enemies with their long bodies
that are maybe around 200 meters or 1000
feet long
at number 3 we have the sand worm so
coming from the movie doom this monster
is the gigantic sand worm of the planet
arrakis they create the spice melange
which is a highly valid resource of the
universe of dune and walls are fought
over it these gigantic sand worms are
also known as the shy hullet are found
in the deserts with big ones that can be
as long as 450 meters or 1500 feet but
are rarely seen
number two alight on the second spot we
have an entry from the mcu show called
loki and this is a trans-dimensional
creature which serves as the guardian of
the void alive is capable of consuming
all of the matter and energy from an
entire timeline or universe and totally
destroying it it is seen as a creature
of smoke and clouds which can extend its
reach as to however far it may want to
at its biggest extent it was around 500
meters or 1650 feet long
and number one the celestials then
lastly we have the space gods of the
movie eternals no one can exactly say
how big these celestials can be but it
seems that these space gods can alter
their size as to their needs the
emerging tier with celestial would have
been hundreds of kilometers or miles
tall while arishim the judge was of
planetary scale and the others that were
seen creating planets and stars would be
in the cosmic scales
and so with that we come to the end of
the video so do hit that like button for
support and click on that subscribe
button as well to be a part of the mind
cue family and most of all smash that
bell icon for regular updates on new
monster content
right here on this channel so till the
next one
take care fam